pictures of utter devastation as
hurricane Dorian turned this town into a
virtual warzone homes and Abaco Islands
have been reduced to piles of rubble
cars tossed like toys now line the
streets the neighborhood has become an
eerie reminder of the enormous damage in
the search for victims and survivors
lifeless bodies are removed from the
rubble surrounded by death and
destruction hope has become a luxury
hope is gone right now but it seems to
be trickling back in is seeing the
people that care that that's come from
outside to show you know that the care
and love and bring in supplies in the
town of Marsh Harbor 90% of homes and
buildings were damaged by Hurricane
durian with winds reaching more than 300
km/h the category 5 hurricane marks the
most powerful Caribbean storm on record
and the capital of nazo authorities have
asked people to open their homes to
evacuate the United Nations estimates
more than 70,000 people are in need of
food and shelter scores of survivors who
lost everything now face the challenge
of starting their lives again the
government if you cannot help us well
you need to give us and let somebody
step in what good could really help us
because we seek help we lost everything
we lost our life we lost our family your
hands peoples are unaccounted for we
could try and find out but all of us we
do our part for lost documents and
everything so there's now a be hard to
find jobs with no documents it will take
years to repair the damage a daunting
process for both rescue teams and
survivors Katia Lopez early on
al-jazeera